[Music]
well here it is the first Star Wars
movie to not make money solo not to its
credit it's not entirely the final
products fault this was the most
expensive Star Wars film because well
everything was reshot originally they
had two different directors making it
but they didn't like the direction was
going so they switched him out with Ron
Howard but they were already deep deep
in production which meant there was a
lot of reshoots and sadly as the
box-office showed it didn't pay off but
even taking that equation out of it solo
is very so so of all the characters I
feel like I'd be interested in knowing
the backstory to solo oddly enough is
not one that I or I found out a lot of
people really needed to know about he's
seen self-explanatory you saw him you
felt like you already know his story but
it turns out you bend and this film is
gonna make you wish you didn't solo
starts out as a young thief with a
girlfriend who steals all sorts of goods
for this giant centipede Muppets little
weird but he decides he wants to do
something with his life so he takes his
girlfriend and they tried to escape the
Empire they get separated though with
her staying behind and him leaving the
planet with a brand new name to solo who
needed the origin of that oh and by the
way the Empire theme that's totally used
in their commercials now whenever the
Emperor lands and returned the Jedi just
wants to be a little marching band
playing that theme the whole time so
weird anywho solo goes from adventure to
adventure from different group of rogues
to other different groups of rogues that
I guess are always smuggling but they're
always smuggling from either the Empire
or some bagged group that he's not
really a bad guy he's not really much of
an outlaw it's like how Bruce Wayne was
never really a criminal because he only
stole from himself
lame his fucking cheaters just make him
a bad guy anyway he meets up with a
giant creature named chewy who we
discover eats people I guess if he walks
can do it why not wookies and his whole
focus is to go from job to job to get
back to the planet to meet up with his
fair luck oh there she is huh not even
halfway through the movie and he just
kind of found her they're not even
really that impressed to see one another
now that you completely robbed the
motive
from this movie where do we go from here
well Holly not the rest of the flick
just kind of feels like they're trying
to find their motivation like he's
trying to figure out what she's up to
and she's trying to figure out what this
other group of bad guys are up to or are
they bad guys and even when you do find
out it's kind of even more confusing
tying in to like the animated Star Wars
movies that you have to have seen to
follow this on top of it being all over
the place without something to really
focus on to lead us through it the
different worlds in this movie are just
kind of ugly I remember them being very
brown and smoky and you can't see a lot
of them sometimes that works out well
like when he meets Lando I want him to
meet in like a dark scuzzy bar like
place but when he's going through the
Kessel run we've gel amid it's kind of
cool to see exactly how he made that
speed it looks like it's through a
tornado's butthole it's just so
unappealing to look at sometimes there
can be an occasional good shot and again
if it's like during a war or something
is supposed to kind of look like world
war one I'm okay with that they're
trying to do in homage but the whole
film looks like this rope one could look
dark and gritty too but you could still
see it it still had a visual sense you
felt like you were there here it just
feels like someone's blowing smoke in
your face the whole time why do I want
to see that in a Star Wars film the
acting for the most part I remember
being okay in the effects I remember
being okay but like I said the
motivation and the focus just didn't
seem there and even when he does do
smuggling stuff it's never actual
smuggling at least not outlaw smuggling
it's going against the Empire these
other bad guys and that's not what I
imagined for Han Solo I remember him
being an actual rogue that's why it made
it interesting when he joins the
rebellion but nope that will make him
too much of a bad guy and that's too
much of a complicated idea so we just
always have to make him good but
honestly that be small potatoes if I
just cared at all and I didn't
I don't need every Star Wars story to be
epic they can be small hell I actually
really like that Cantina scene from the
holiday special that was great and it
had no epicness in it at all I loved it
I heard they were gonna do a movie on
moss eisely
I would totally be down for that but
here it feels like it's trying to be a
small story and a big story at the same
time and be
cuz of that they can't really keep it
focused it's just another movie it
doesn't even really feel like Star Wars
it just feels like this sci-fi flick
about this guy that kind of goes from
thing to thing and then it's over
even the people who like it say they
enjoy it but they kind of forget about
it shortly after I guess that's not the
biggest crime but for something like
Star Wars whether it be incredibly good
or incredibly bad there has to be
something incredible about it and
there's definitely nothing like that
here
[Music]